[Music]
big time rush is back with a brand new
single as the guys are ready to hit the
road together on their first headline
tour in nearly a decade carlos kendall
logan and james all join us now actually
um guys by the way welcome thank you as
much as i'd love to replace james as the
fourth member of big time rush he is
with us
what's going on james i am here via zoom
i'm actually just around the corner i
just really wanted to be blown up twice
as large on the bridge
wait wait you're in the band right thank
you yeah and by the way i'm just a sub i
would never replace you james
i'm a substitute hey but where are you
i'm in atlanta i was in l.a with the
boys just a few hours ago hopped on the
red eye to come back uh filming a movie
out here i love it i love well thanks
all of you guys for joining us
absolutely some big things are happening
for big time right now uh you guys just
announced that you are going on tour for
the first time in like eight years
something like that yeah you know right
yeah it's just a long time and i know
let's just say a few years
some time has passed but obviously fans
are so excited about it you guys seem
genuinely geeked out about it so who do
we have to think for literally getting
the band back together this is it
tequila
i heard y'all were drinking tequila yeah
yes we did do a little bit of that when
we were writing some songs but um
truthfully it was all of us we've been
wanting to do this for a long time and
timing either didn't work out with one
person or two people it just was trying
to figure out how to put it all together
and then finally um actually about the
end of 2019 we decided to yeah we
decided we were doing this and
the world had a different idea we have
to wait yeah the server lining was that
we had a lot of time to focus on our
friendship and the studio time so it was
really a beautiful thing yeah i feel
like timing is perfect right now though
right because live music is coming back
you guys have had some time to like be
in the studio and do your thing in fact
your single not giving you up is out
today
i love it congratulations who came up
with the uh we'll give it what the nerdy
office vibes look for the video like
who's like a big fan of office space
here i mean office space and the office
right yeah
well i mean it was a group effort i
think you know kendall really led this
whole marketing strategy and you know
getting just the the video and the song
and piecing it all together you were
talking about tequila there was a little
bit to keep it okay
this time around it's so different
because
it's it's our show now so we get to make
the decisions we are we are the creators
we want to wear stupid outfits with with
ties we are going to do it i'm going to
do it that's what you're going to see
now i love it you guys are redefining
boy band swagger huh here we go hey i'll
take it uh james what's it like to be
back on a set with these guys i mean
honestly it seemed like we hadn't taken
any time off at all we all worked so
well together and part of the reason we
did this is we wanted to
have the fun that we had back in the day
but what i don't think we expected is
just how much fun we're gonna have this
time around everything from writing
music to making our first video together
has just been fantastic that's so
awesome it's so good to see you guys
back together what was it like trying to
get you know those elements of big time
rush back into it both in the studio but
also in your videos and your visuals
like what was it like to kind of like
put that hat back on it took a little
while
you know right in the pandemic we were
writing over zoom and some of them a
little more successful than others but
uh once we all actually got together in
real life we just kind of just
it went back to kind of feeling like it
did before and we found a new sound and
we worked on it and i think we're still
kind of finding that but it's been a
great process was it like riding a bike
again pretty much yeah i mean you don't
forget to hang out with these guys yeah
of course definitely had the training
wheels for a little bit yeah absolutely
but yeah but you guys have been around
for a minute and we were there at the
very very beginning in fact we talked to
you guys for the first time in 2010
on the set of the show and i want to
play a little clip for you guys
oh boy can't wait okay you guys are
superstars you're the big new boy band
so this is what i was just asking russ
about i mean do you think that this is
the comeback of the boy band
you know we're not trying to
to copy anything we're and we're kind of
reinvented i think we're having fun all
four of us have totally different voices
and they've created this band and we're
going with it
yeah
right and i think it's it's unique that
we're all you know four lead singers
normally you know there's there's the uh
the nick or the you know
aj or whatever it was but uh you know
who is that guy just looking at you like
dancing and playing logan's like having
a good time yeah so tell us a little bit
about this
oh my god
thank you so much for having us
listen up this way e.t does well we have
the vault but they literally said are we
bringing back the boy back i think we
did we did and we're doing it again
you're doing it again you guys are
holding it down for the boy band come on
take us back to the casting process of
that nickelodeon show what do you
remember about it and did you even
realize like what it would become it was
a lengthy process i think we did four
different screen tests we shot a whole
pilot but the biggest thing i remember
is thinking man i hope this thing
actually goes and then if it does would
it be worth it i mean it's been years of
our lives now none of us could have ever
predicted that it would be as successful
and at the scale that it turned out to
be and i remember us walking from day
one we've just been grateful the
paramount lot and we were we're going is
this going to be good is this is this
kind of like worth it but i knew we had
so much fun and it really just turned
out to be something bad you know what
fun fact we shot a pilot without this
guy really yeah somebody else playing
his character no i can't i can't
and you know what it just didn't have
the right vibe uh he was super talented
but it wasn't the right vibe and we were
so lucky to find to find kendall and it
was like
he came into the room and the three of
us just knew like this was the guy
that's amazing i was gonna say i think
what's also really special about this
whole experience is your guys's bond
because you can't predict that and
control that either like you guys would
actually love it
come on uh listen a lot has changed
since then right you guys have all been
booed up during hiatus
um
are your wives and your girlfriends how
excited are they that you guys are
getting back together i think i think
mika is just happy to see me out of the
house
no it's just they're really excited and
obviously she they all know how much
this means to us and so um it's just
nothing but support i mean we all in
fact they're always constantly
facetiming our partners and everybody
like that it's just it's so great
haven't been able to see these kids
right great kids they haven't been able
to see the shows
so now they're singing for the first
time
and you know what my my whole family's
coming on tour really we have our own
bus okay i love that and we're doing the
same thing you're babysitting you have
three babysitters i mean this is kind of
amazing i know i would trust that with
my kids i didn't sign up to be honest
maybe for like james says i didn't sign
up for that but
here's what i want to know carlos
carlos who's more rowdy energetic this
group or your family of toddlers oh man
i can i can control my family of
toddlers i can't control these guys
speaking of rapidly winter without
tequila might be a good ride yes on that
note by the way i love that your fans
have grown up with you some of them can
drink now at your shows i hope you guys
get a cut of the alcohol sales
okay most of them yeah when we were
playing shows in december it was kind of
surreal to look out and see there were
no parents it was all young adults yeah
big time rushed tequila brent hey listen
that's
dream big manifest that okay we need to
that's how i'm gonna be enjoying your
show when i go see you on the votes
right which tickets are on sale today
and also real quick dixie demilio yeah
on tour with you guys
she's she's great yeah she hung out with
her yesterday it was so much fun and um
she's just i think she's really excited
we found out that she's a big fan of the
band yeah which of course for us is kind
of weird you know when anyone says like
i mean even still anyone on the street
says oh my god i love the band it's like
it's trippy you know after all these
years football and she was fantastic so
we're super happy to have some portable
too we're going to have to learn uh some
tick tock stuff because we're terrible
and she is like the queens right there
you have a source daniel's trying to do
tick-tock
i have a feeling we might be
overthinking it no i think maybe at
least one open it up that's all i'm
saying
all right new single not giving you up
is out today and also tickets for the
summer tour are also on sale right now
so go get them go cop em i know i will
yeah
[Music]